[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
rassurez vous on n'a pas oublié qu'il ya
des élections sénatoriales aujourd'hui
en france mais pour respecter les règles
et le vote des grands électeurs
aujourd'hui on vous en parlera en détail
ce soir dans le 19 20 mai pas ce matin
pour le moment direction les états unis
à un peu plus d'un mois du grand soir
on assiste au combat entre le sortant
républicain donald trump et le démocrate
joe biden un choix radicalement
différent pour une amérique plus divisé
que jamais avec un scrutin qui
entraînera d'importantes conséquences
sur nous aussi marche du monde
diplomatie échanges commerciaux vis des
américains dans notre région que
changerait la réélection de donald trump
pour l'élection de joe biden et que
dirait ce choix de la société américaine
mais aussi de l'avenir de la planète
on en débat ce matin avec nos invités à
liszt meyer bonjour je vous êtes maître
de conférences en civilisation
américaine à l'université de bourgogne
corentin c'est là bonjour vous êtes
professeur d'histoire en classe
préparatoire à dijon spécialiste des
états unis jeffrey kling bonjour bonjour
vous êtes citoyen américain directeur du
master grande école de bsb l'école de
commerce de dijon pierre gernelle
bonjour vous êtes directeur général de
la fédération des négociants éleveurs de
la grande bourgogne on parlera business
avec vous évidemment
merci à tous d'être là merci à vous de
nous suivre et de commenter en direct
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
dit mme paul bourgogne alors peut-être
tout d'abord un point sur la situation
aux etats-unis aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
motive la campagne en ce moment est-ce
que vous pouvez nous le dira l'ex
meilleur est ce que ce sont on a
beaucoup parlé les émeutes suite aux
violences policières l'épidémie ducobu
et ses conséquences économiques
ou alors peut-être que sûrement même
qu'on va en parler très rapidement la
question du nouveau juge à la cour
suprême etc
mais c'est un peu de tout ça en même
temps en fait qui aliment de la campagne
la campagne et dans un contexte qui est
incroyablement compliqué historiquement
compliqué pour les raisons que vous avez
cités et au delà de ça moi je
rajouterais en plus la problématique de
la présidence trump en elle-même et de
l'opposition qui est qui est assez
intense face à un président qui est
considéré comme
atypique voire anormal et donc il ya une
opposition très forte face à lui tout
comme de son côté un soutien assez assez
fort aussi c'est pas un prisme européen
ça la difficulté d'intégrer donald trump
comme à la fois un président en exercice
et en même temps un futur président
peut-être corentin c'est là est ce que
vraiment aux états unis il y à une forte
opposition
oui c'est ce qui ressort de tous les
sondages d'approbation présidentielle
c'est vraiment il a une structure
d'approbation dans l'opinion qui est
constant c'est à dire que il a un socle
vraiment de partisans acharnés qui sont
qui sont pour lui quoi qu'il fasse mais
qui ne sont pas une majorité ça ça forme
une minorité de la population entre
toujours entre 40 et 45% et on a un tout
petit peu plus de 50% des états uniens
qui le désapprouvent très fortement
sauf que ces sondages d'approbation ils
se retrouveront pas nécessairement dans
les urnes donc bon là il faut voir la
dynamique de l'élection mais il est
extrêmement clivant et c'est ce qui
ressort effectivement depuis quatre ans
dans les sondages d'opinion jeffrey
klein les américains ont quel
préoccupation aujourd'hui au moment où
on parle pour cette élection c'est quoi
qui va déterminer leur vote selon vous
moi je crois à l'avenir c'est très
difficile de se voir qu'est ce qui se
passe après parce que on a déjà eu une
nation assez divisé dont un dernier en 1
1 deux ans et on ne sait pas s'il sera
encore plus haut avec tube hayden sera
plus de sécurité plus
sinteo on ne sait pas exactement audio
bein il n'est pas très connu comme mon
président il est très connu comme vice
président allemand comme président on ne
sait pas exactement donc l'avenir
c'est très rare ouverte où le moment ce
sont des candidats américains on imagine
qu'à pas des différences fondamentales
par exemple d'un point de vue économique
même si
donald trump a tendance à dire moi c'est
l'ordre et la justice et puis à côté
c'est le chaos sont pas des communistes
non plus contrairement à ce que à ce
qu'on a pu entendre dire parfois non
c'est sûr mais par contre il faut bien
voir que les deux sont sont quand même à
des positions idéologiques très
différentes
joe biden est le porte parole du parti
démocrate cette année enfin le le la
personne qui va porter la candidature
démocrate et scellés sont programmées le
plus à gauche de l'histoire du parti
démocrate en fait donc à des
propositions vraiment marqué le problème
c'est que donald trump de son côté lui
aussi est ancrée très fortement à droite
il est le fruit en fait sont à son
accession est le fruit de la
polarisation partisane
donc c'est cette poussée des extrêmes
ans aux états unis qui font que les
positions sont en fait assez marquées et
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
même si joe biden est finalement n'est
pas bernie sanders
de fait ces positions sont très à gauche
par rapport à l'habitude le ma crainte
au delà du remplacement de bail donne
par trump ou pas c'est surtout qu'en
fait quelle que soit la personne qui va
être en place c'est ces problématiques
de polarisation et de divisions au sein
de la mission américaine vont persister
et même une présidence biden ne sera pas
amen d'une je pense comme on a pu le
voir avec la présidence obama à réussir
à ressouder une nation américaine qui
est en train de se diviser de manière
assez assez grave je pense qu'on rentre
à cela c'est la première fois qu'on voit
une élection aussi clivé avec des oui
comme le disait très bien l'ex meilleur
c'est vraiment l'aboutissement on va
dire d'un quart de siècle de
polarisation partisane qui font que les
deux parties se sont radicalisées
essentiellement est d'abord les
républicains mais le parti démocrate
commence également à aller plus vers sa
gauche alors avec ce double paradoxe qui
est qui était évoquée par monsieur klein
c'est que jobs ait donné un candidat
extrêmement centriste mais qui porte le
programme le plus à gauche des années
récentes pour les démocrates notamment
parce qu'il avait dû faire des
concessions pendant la primaire avec
excès a mis exactement il a dû arranger
on va dire les choses avec bernie
sanders et ses amis et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il ya une grande inconnue sur
la personne de joe biden parce qu'il est
c'est un candidat c'est le candidat le
plus âgé de toute l'histoire 118 ans
brigué la présidence il a 78 ans il a
déjà eu de très gros problèmes de santé
il ya une trentaine d'années donc on a
une à cette incertitude là c'est un
homme qui à presque 50 ans de carrière
politique aussi alors que généralement
les démocrates récemment optait plutôt
pour le renouvellement donc on a on a
cette incertitude là et en face on à
l'incertitude qui hélas dû à la personne
de trump qui clivent en permanence qui
est qui est dans la provocation en
permanence mais change d'avis voilà donc
on a une double incertitude qui se fait
face et c'est compliqué de voir ce qui
peut se passer dans quelle mesure des
facs et la situation sanitaire du pays
deux cent mille morts qu'elle va peser
selon vous sur cette élection
bah c'est mon job and il a déjà proposé
ici il devient de nouveau président et
il a déjà déclaré il va suivre les
consignes étaient sains donc il va
suivre un protocole précise et exacte
mis en doute par moments par donald
trump pendant son mandat
voilà c'est bien lui il va toujours
essayer de faire un petit peu de dames
plaît là la crise donc il ya deux choses
complètement différentes radios
oui donc moi je crois si les américains
va
orienté vers les crises sanitaires
giovanni là en gros 20 h la notamment
parce que de l'attrait pas mal géré
cette crise on peut dire ça alors en
tout cas on vient de passer le cap des
200 milles morts aux etats unis ce qui
rapporté au nombre d'habitants est bien
supérieur par exemple à ce qu'a connu la
france donc incontestablement il ya eu
un grand choc de la copie 19 et surtout
peut-être que donald trump s'est mis
lui-même dans l'embarras au début de la
crise d'abord en lannion et puis en
faisant des prévisions sur les chiffres
de mort qui serait acceptable qui
aujourd'hui lui revienne en pleine
figure au fur et à mesure qu en
annonçant lui même qui vous prenez de
l'hydroxyde qui alors ça peut être un
petit peu moins quand on ne sera
peut-être moins marquée qu'en europe
mais plus quand il a dit voilà si s'il
ya cent mille morts ce sera un très bon
résultat et puis après il a changé et ça
ça va donner une impression quand même
assez désastreuse il faut bien le dire
et pourtant dans les sondages alex meyer
quand on interroge les américains on
voit que la première préoccupation pour
choisir un bon président c'est les
questions économiques la relance
l'emploi est ce que je vais avoir du
travail est ce que je vais gagner
décemment ma vie ça reste ça l'enjeu
bien sûr mais je crois que c'est
indissociable en fait de la gestion de
la crise de la copie aussi puisque de
dire que l'on a soit la crise sanitaire
sur la crise économique en fait c'est
faux puisque quand on à l'agressivité on
à la crise économique
l'attelage est de fermer que ce soit de
droit ou de fait
donc en fait la gestion catastrophique
de la crise engendre des cris d une
situation économique qui est aussi
catastrophique et qui finit aussi par
nuire à sa popularité même si comme l'a
très bien rappelé mon collègue corentin
cei de fait son socle électoral reste
très stable mais depuis son élection il
a été élu par une minorité d'américains
cette minorité d'américains continuent
de le soutenir et il le soutiendrons
enfin clairement si le soutient encore
aujourd'hui il le soutient on a
l'impression que c'est jamais gagné
rappelez vous il ya quelques années de
cela vu d'europe on dise
et à mes hillary clinton à boulevard et
en fait on s'est rendu compte que c'est
donald trump qui a été élu donc ça veut
donc dire que ça n'est jamais gagné
d'avancé que c'est dans ces élections
tout peut changer notamment en raison du
collège électoral a absolument il faut
vraiment martelé ça pour nous
téléspectateurs c'est un jour un jour
d'élections sénatoriales en france on
peut peut-être comprendre convoyage de
grands électeurs s'est passé c'est un
suffrage indirect avec un collège de
grands électeurs par état et donc il ne
s'agit pas d'avoir à la majorité au
suffrage populaire mais il s'agit
d'avoir la majorité des grands électeurs
et donc aujourd'hui incontestablement le
voit depuis 20 ans ce collège des grands
électeurs favorise les républicains
conservateurs surévaluent en particulier
les petits états ruraux de l'amérique du
centre à l'autre est propre tron très
pro trump et donc il a un petit avantage
il pourrait d'ailleurs être réélu de
nouveau en étant minoritaire en voix sur
l'ensemble du territoire il faut bien
rappeler alors au moment où on
enregistre cette émission il faut le
savoir la la nouvelle juge de la cour
suprême n'a pas encore été nommé le nom
que veut proposer donald trump n'est pas
encore connue néanmoins la mort de ruth
bader ginsburg a marqué ces derniers
jours aux etats-unis est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire dans quelle mesure j'ai
demandé à des frais mais dans quelle
mesure à des frais qu'elle dans quelle
mesure ça revêt une importance telle
parce que vu d'ici on comprend pas
toujours
bah ça change tout parce que si ces
troncs pas nominé cas quand ça va
changer tout il y aura en majorité 6 à 3
donc avec des justes qui sont élus elle
vient donc sont nommés à vie
oui oui donc cette décision ça va durer
longtemps
donc la décision très très important
pour les états unis sera dans le monde
toujours d'un républicain en cloud oc
cette à l'action donc plus en plus son
pad qu'est ce qui se passe avec ça
donc parce que la cour suprême a un rôle
bien plus important est très différent
d'un conseil constitutionnel chez nous
au delà de la personnalité de cette juge
décédé c'est aussi l'importance du rôle
de la cour suprême aux états unis
exactement la cour suprême a un rôle
particulièrement important dans le
politique américain et c'est d'autant
plus vrai à mesure que les autres les
autres pouvoirs en fait tendent à être
un petit peu dysfonctionne
dysfonctionnelle le congrès des états
unis par exemple est bloqué dans de
manière systématique par l'opposition
entre les parties du coup les décisions
sont prises
et de fait les décisions se finissent
toujours à la cour suprême ça a été le
cas pour le mariage homosexuel
c'était le cas c'est notamment toute la
jurisprudence sur l'avortement et donc
c'est là où ça devient extrêmement
dangereux et extrêmement important de
savoir qui siègent à la cour suprême
et là il a matériellement le temps de
nommer une juge donald trump ou est-ce
que ça va être plus compliqué jeudi une
parce que visiblement il ultra
conservatrice alors oui il sera sera une
juge mais il faut dissocier de temps lui
va donner un nom va va nommer une juge
et ensuite il ya le temps de la
confirmation par le sénat
c'est sur ce temps là qui a une petite
incertitude mais les sénateurs
républicains se sont rangés finalement
du côté du président est normalement il
prévoit un vote de confirmation juste
avant l'élection elle pourrait même être
déjà en place installée est confirmée
par le sénat au moment de l'élection
présidentielle le 3 novembre dans un
délai très très rapide pierre vernel est
ce que vous faites avant d'en venir
évidemment à la question du vin puisque
vous représentez ici les négociant de
vins de bourgogne mais avant ça est ce
que vous faites une différence d'un
point de vue économique vous entre joe
biden et donald trump est ce que vous
vous dites il ya il ya une grande
différence ou finalement dans nos
rapports nos échanges avec les états
unis ça ne changera pas grand chose
quelle que soit l'issue de l'élection à
on peut dire que
on n'y a pas forcément une grosse
différence en fait parce que on sent
qu'il ya un mouvement qui est là depuis
quelques années qui dépasse les états
unis qui est une espèce de retour à une
forme de protectionnisme économique lié
à la montée des populismes aux débats
aux clivages parce qu'on parle des
clivages aux états unis on pourrait
parler du clivage en grande bretagne
voire en france voire dans pas mal de
pays on sent bien que maintenant les
relations politiques sont assez
exacerbée williams et protectionnisme
c'est au delà de la personne même de
donald trump sont plus profonds vous le
voyez dans d'autres pays on voit on voit
des tentatives oui on la sort on l'a vu
par exemple il ya bien sûr la relation
entre l'union européenne et la chine et
la chine avaient il ya déjà quelques
années mener une enquête antidumping
contre les vins français en réaction une
enquête antidumping contre les panneaux
solaires chinois
donc effectivement on sent bien qu'ils
aient à ce mouvement donald trump
clairement à s'inscrit dans ce mouvement
moi je me souviens que dans le programme
de hillary clinton
il y avait aussi quand même des notions
de protectionnisme à ce niveau là on est
donc pour le coup pour nous on fait pas
vraiment une grande différence
même si ces deux partis enfin ses deux
représentants sont entre guillemets
enfin avec nos termes à nous des
libéraux c'est à dire qu'ils croient
dans les échanges internationaux
mais effectivement moi je vois que
depuis la crise de 2008 qui a quand même
fortement ébranlé l'économie américaine
et notre également anglaise on sent bien
que aux états unis a vraiment un besoin
des citoyens de se sentir protégée par
rapport aux échanges internationaux de
frais klein les américains ils sont de
toutes façons donald trump ou pas ils
sont protectionnistes je pense
ça change à base de président je pense
je pense qu'ils sont anti poutine cité
par le président de penser à versailles
ça dépendra aussi celui qui ont émis ici
les académies ça marche très bien
ça va changer la vie des américains qui
est alors s'il ya quelque chose qui
voulait être protectionniste mais si
d'économie ça marche très bien donc ils
sont moins moins de soucis alors on va
partir du postulat que l'économie va mal
marché dans les prochains mois il ya de
fortes chances après la crise de
l'épidémie de gros navires us voilà
alors du coup est-ce qu'il va y avoir
une différence pour nos échanges
commerciaux
bah moi je pense que c'est quand même un
domaine sur lequel le président peut
agir de manière assez unilatérale ce qui
est une délégation de pouvoir de la part
du congrès sur ces question donc de ce
point de vue là le choix de la personne
a une conséquence et on peut espérer en
tout cas de notre point de vue que si
c'est une présidence bailon nier une
normalisation un petit peu des relations
commerciales qui sont particulièrement
conflictuelle sous la présidence de
normalisation oui mais on gardera
peut-être quelques taxes quand même
qu'en wi surtout qu'il faut pas oublier
que le parti démocrate est donc la
gauche est aujourd'hui traversée par le
débat libre échange protectionnistes
bernie sanders donc le leader de la
gauche du parti démocrate et défend
aussi une forme de protectionnisme
défense des emplois ou non des normes
environnementales sociales or évidemment
c'est pas du tout le même
protectionnisme que donald trump
mais il ya quand même dans une partie de
la gauche étasunienne la remise en cause
du libre échange et donc là dessus
d'ailleurs ce sera peut-être un sujet de
friction si c'est une présidence byden
entre les centristes et la gauche du
parti démocrate
vraiment le libre échange et
protectionnisme c'est vraiment une
fracture possible quand je vous écoute
j'ai l'impression que ça ressemble un
petit peu au débat qui peut y avoir chez
nous entre l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche qui sont par moments tous les
deux protectionnistes alors que alors
qu'ils sont ils n'ont pas la même vision
l'économie oui mais c'est pas alors
s'est passé vraiment plutôt une remise
en cause du libre échange mais pas du
tout pour les mêmes raisons chez bernie
sanders c'est vraiment la notion de
d'avoir une concurrence
scènes qui ne repose pas sur
l'exploitation de travailleurs dans
d'autres pays qui repose aussi sur une
une bonne santé environnementale pour
tous les pays participant au processus
de production mais de fait en tout cas
ce que ça nous montre c'est que la
gauche aussi est traversée par ce débat
aujourd'hui à une remise en cause du
dogme du libre-échange et la
mondialisation dont vous pensez aussi
que si joe biden a été lu ça sera quand
même différent ce que disait l'ex mari
en a en tout cas ce sera différent de la
présidence obama est il ya quelque chose
qui a été remise en cause c'est ce dogme
de la mondialisation heureuse du libre
échange et ça vraiment oui ce sera
différent mais avec byron on ne
reviendra pas dessus pierre gernelle
j'imagine que vous regardez ces
élections quand même de très près
notamment parce que depuis un an il ya
la fameuse taxe trump de 25% qui est
papa polluent la vie mais qui vous
contrarie quand même ici parce que c'est
25% à 2 valorem donc ce qui valait 100
votants 25 est clairement pour les vins
de bourgogne c'est à peu près 40 % de
chiffre d'affaires en moins c'est à peu
près sur l'année on va faire les comptes
à la fin de l'année mais on parle de 80
millions d'euros en moins au niveau
national c'est à peu près 415 millions
d'euros de perte de business donc c'est
considérable les etats unis c'est notre
premier pays client et donc on a vu bien
sûr l'impact tout de suite de cette taxe
on savait très bien qu'on allait
souffrir c'est dès lors qu'on était
désigné par contre ce que je tiens à
dire par rapport à ces taxes concis
qu'on nomme taxe trump c'est qu'elle se
fait dans le cadre d'un contentieux
international de haut niveau de l'om
c'est ce sont ces la suite c'est là on
va dire le résultat d'une procédure qui
avait 15 ans qui concerne l'aéronautique
le conflit airbus boeing est donc le mca
sanctionné l'union européenne et a dit
aux états unis que il était tout à fait
dans leur droit de lever cet axe est
donc quelque part donald trump à travers
cette taxe ne s'est pas affranchi des
règles ou n'a pas pris une position
unilatérale il règle reste finalement
dans cette logique multilatérale même si
on sait que c'est compliqué parce qu'il
ya le volet boeing qui doit
surgir après et malheureusement ils
bloquent pour le moment le désignation
des arbitres au niveau de l'om c'est
l'om s'est complètement bloquée
directeur général a d'ailleurs
démissionné et on sait que ça va être
compliqué pour avoir le volet pendant le
boeing qui doit sortir dans quelques
semaines normalement et puis a le choix
des cibles quand même qu'il a pour le
coup et le choix de trump d'attaquer les
vins français et encore pas tous et pas
les vins pas tous les vins européens
ça c'est quand même un choix c'est trop
calculer sachant que les vins français
c'est comme quand on attaque automobile
en allemagne
on sait que ça va réagir voilà on sait
là c'est un symbole
on présente un symbole représente aussi
un volant d'affaires encore une fois la
chine en 2012
attaquer les vars et européens parce que
c'est des races étaient encore une fois
c'est pas etats unis france ou chine
france et chaque fois au niveau de
l'union européenne
mais c'est vrai que on a visé les vins
français 5 d'union européenne parce que
c'est très symbolique
il ya aussi un autre dossier qui est en
cours c'est la négociation sur la
fameuse taxe gafa qui doit être appliqué
par la france alors là pour le coup
c'est une relation france etats unis
et là aussi donald trump brandi la
menace de rim baltagui nation de taxes
sur les spiritueux pardon sur les
effervescents pour le moment il a mis ça
de côté
c'est plus d'actualité mais ça peut
revenir
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
élection si jo byden passé vous pour
vous pensez que cette taxe aurait des
chances de disparaître même si vous
dites qu'elle est dans le cas du niveau
social
effectivement comment parler de
normalisation on peut espérer que dans
le cadre on va dire d'un retour un
dialogue plus constructif entre les
états unis et l'union européenne
avec en plus le on va dire de nouveau le
jeu actif de l'om sait on peut espérer
d'avoir des débats un peu plus sereins
qu'ils soient moins on va dire menée par
logique de rapport de force comme c'est
le cas pour le moment ceci étant dit on
reste prudent c'est pas parce que joe
baden as rêve que tout d'un coup on est
dans une logique de
des changes de libre échangisme 100 ans
sans contrainte
il y avait un projet d'accord qui
s'appelait l'accord taffetas entre les
états unis et l'union européenne qui
étaient mille côté pour le moment on
n'est pas sûr que ça puisse revenir
rapidement même avec joe biden c'est là
toute façon ça rejoint aussi la le choix
stratégiques café donald trump
il faut écrit que le slogan america
frost qui doivent prix est vraiment
appliqué à la lettre donc un mal quelque
chose c'est l'amérique d'abord donc
effectivement c'est toujours les
intérêts américains et on se soucie pas
des alliés traditionnels et on n'a aucun
intérêt pour l'histoire le passé commun
et c'est pour ça que les américains
l'ont élu oui oui c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très clair et c'est aussi
l'amérique c'est devenu de plus en plus
la mairie que seules ou signe un
vraiment la puissance unilatérale seul
ce qui changera peut-être avec byden
c'est qu'on reviendra à une logique
quand même de construction de l'alliance
de de partage ou non du passé commun de
plus grand respect de l'alliance qui
voudra pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
désaccord mais disons que l'attitude a
priori sera moins dur et moins
rigoureuse des faca rassurez-moi les
américains aiment toujours le vin de
bourgogne
ah oui absolument ouais ouais donc il
continue à en consommer oui de toute
velléité plus cher continue en consommer
et effectivement il faut savoir une
chose aussi par rapport à cette taxe
quand il a été mis en place c'est qu'il
ya eu vraiment monté au créneau de tous
les importateurs tous les acteurs de la
distribution de vins français aux états
unis c'était parce qu'il ya eu des
procédures d et labellisation c-max
isation il ya plus de 1000 sociétés
américaines qui se sont insurgés contre
ce projet de taxe et qui continue
d'ailleurs de se battre parce qu'il faut
savoir quels principes de revoir
finalement la liste des produits taxés
tous les six mois à peu près ça a était
repassé là cet été ça va repasser au
début d'année prochaine
et chaque fois beaucoup d'américains se
mobilisent pour de nouveau voir cette
taxe
disparaître est clairement au niveau de
la population et magath et on les
remercie parce que ça reste quand même
notre premier pays client en chiffre
d'affaires les américains continuent de
boire des vins de bourgogne
jeff klein au niveau de l'image alors
vous êtes dans notre région depuis
relativement peu de temps mais vous
travaillez en europe depuis très
longtemps
au niveau de l'image que nous avons de
vous américain est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ces quatre dernières
années l'image qu'on a eue de vous a
changé par donald trump
oui absolument et malheureusement oui
j'ai pas mal de gens qui viennent de
parler avec moi ils voulaient se voir
mon avis dès qu'est ce qui se passe et
pourquoi cette gros changements aux
états unis donc c'est tout un changement
ainsi pour moi est moins des fois j'ai
mis d'identifier plus des caisses qui se
passe aux etats unis la violence dans la
roue d'un gros gros manifestation le
problème avec la police la brutalité ça
le segmentation de donc tout ça j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté dédain des fines
et moi même
donc quand vous parlez avec les français
les européens ce que vous avez
l'impression aux considère que les
américains sont racistes par exemple
deux fois peut-être
ouais ouais mais en même temps il se
pose des questions parce que les états
tennis est très difficilement considérer
la melting potes dont ils sont pas
chaudes et qu'est ce qui se passe parce
qu'ils voient la mise les images sous
les télévisions mais comme m
il ya beaucoup de des autres
l'immigration des gens qui viennent tout
ornement milliers de travailler pour
vivre en sérénité donc il sait pas
qu'est ce qui se passe ils supportent
exactement la réalité
donc ils posent des questions en matière
d'image on n'a pas parlé il ya un
personnage important c'est kamala harris
celle qui fait un ticket avec joe biden
pour être peut-être un jour la première
vice-présidente des etats-unis ça va
être un élément important de cette
campagne un élément important levier se
débat aussi entre les candidats la vice
président tout à fait le vice-président
a pas non plus un rôle essentiel au
niveau de l'élection c'est pas la raison
pour laquelle les gens choisissent l'un
ou l'autre des candidats
mais c'est toujours un rôle de symbole
et elles peuvent le dessus sur la
personnalité de joe biden impressionnant
qui n'a pas une personnalité
particulièrement charismatique mais pour
rebondir un petit peu sur ce qu'on
disait c'est vrai qu'on a tendance nous
de notre côté à associer les américains
à la personne de leur président alors on
avait vu le ca de manière assez
caricatural après la présidence bush
n'avait obama et l'hôte d'un coup là
c'était formidable de travailler sur les
états unis alors qu'avant c'était
horrible mais de fait si on en est
vraiment juste à ce type de symbole on
sait aussi et nous en tant qu'enseignant
on a tendance à marteler toujours que
ils sont 330 millions de personnes il
n'y a pas une personne pour les
représenter surtout quand c'est une
personne qui est élu par une minorité de
la population et parce que depuis début
on dit les américains mais il ya un
nombre incroyable d'américains c'est
difficile de les cataloguer il ya des
régions tellement différente des états
tels vous venez de chicago de la région
de chicago il ya des états tellement
différentes
oui d'ailleurs c'est un des risques à
venir après l'élection parce qu'on voit
un tel degré de polarisation de violence
et 2
on a l'impression de deux nations qui
s'éloigne à l'intérieur de la nation
étasunienne qui devrait être unis on
voit des territoires qui ne partagent
plus rien ni les mêmes valeurs ni
parfois les mêmes lois parce que des
lois diffèrent d'état à état et c'est
vraiment le risque pour les états unis
après les skull l'élection
éventuellement merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi on va suivre avec
attention le premier débat des candidats
sera mardi prochain aux états unis
dans un instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale suivi de la partie nationale
de dimension politique francis letellier
reçoit philippe martinez le secrétaire
général de la cgt bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]